c'est sur le site de ce dépôt à neige
dans une ancienne carrière que tout
nouveau quartier sera créé d'iran comme
68 terrain de football
le carré laval sera situé au beau milieu
du centre ville
tout juste à côté de l'autoroute 15 au
sud du boulevard saint martin est un
actif de 80 millions qu'on a qu'on va
mettre à la disposition des citoyens
on veut développer au niveau
l'innovation mais un respectant
l'environnement
le projet comprend l'aménagement d'une
place publique donnant accès à un lac
artificiel
on veut construire de deux à trois mille
logements attirer des entreprises et des
centres de recherche
l'administration du maire marc demers
estime que le carré laval sera bien
positionnée pour obtenir la désignation
de zones d'innovation si fameux pôles de
haute technologie que veut développer le
gouvernement legault parce que laval peu
avant une ovation réponse et où il faut
trouver la thématique
une thématique qui vont réunir les gens
ça c'est important il faut aussi avoir
l'argent du privé le gouvernement
remettre la plus la charge à la batterie
c'est un troll le projet du carré laval
représente un virage à 180 degrés le
nouveau quartier sera entièrement
piétonnier une première dans cette ville
qui est le paradis de la voiture pour
assurer la réussite du projet il faudra
y amener un réseau de transports en
commun dignes de ce nom soit
prolongement du rêve jusqu'à laval qui
pourrait passer d'un secteur où soit la
ligne orageuse venant de côte vertu
ce quartier là va y avoir plein
d'activités va attirer des travailleurs
va attirer peut-être des gens pour des
loisirs
donc si on a pas de transports en commun
à disposition les gens vont venir
naturellement en voiture le prolongement
du métro et du rem font présentement
l'objet d'études
mais pour l'instant québec ne veut
compromettre ici olivier vachon
radio-canada laval